on en sait un peu plus concernant la
réponse immunitaire après la maladie
selon une étude scientifique menée par
des chercheurs français et publiée hier
dans la revue nature nature
communications
cette réponse immunitaire liés à la
production d'anticorps à la suite d'une
forme modérée ducobu 19 s'étend
rapidement à partir de deux mois un
délai relativement faibles donc nous
avons reçu aujourd'hui l'éclairage de
pierre tattevin épidémiologistes et chef
du service des maladies infectieuses du
chu de rennes et coûteuse alors c'est
une étude très intéressante parce qu'ils
ont essayé de regarder chez des
soignants qui avait contracté la kovy
donner une forme pas très grave
combien de temps dure la présence
d'anticorps qui permettent de
neutraliser le virus est ce qu'ils ont
montré leurs études ils ont trois points
à 3 semaines et mois et trois mois et il
montre pour ça commence déjà à descendre
2ème et le 3ème mois ce qui chez des
soignants qui avait pas de problème de
santé particulier auparavant et plutôt
assez rapide effectivement qu alors il
est possible qu'avec ce virus-là plus on
fait une forme grave puis on a une
immunité solide derrière
c'est pas vrai pour tous les virus n'est
pour celui là ça semble relativement
vrai